hello boyle after you're done here meet
me in my office i have something i need
to ask you
it's food related i will bring my a game
oh my god gina captain holt just asked
me into his office
for a food related question yes i heard
and that's how i know i don't care i've
wanted to build a rapport with him since
he got here but until now
all we've had in common was our bank
guess who nypd hands up
this is great i had no idea captain holt
was interested in food
i have zero interest in food if it were
feasible my diet would consist
entirely of flavorless beige smoothies
containing all the nutrients
required by the human animal so our bank
got some new atms huh
i wouldn't know i have switch banks oh
no anyway tomorrow's my
anniversary with kevin i'd like to cook
him an impressive breakfast
could you help orient me with that
process i'd be honored
preparing food for one's lover is the
most intimate gift of all
aside from washing their hair
morning everyone morning sir hey look
we're food stained buds who are you
wearing porridge
um oatmeal
hello partner two coffees black for me
milk for you you remembered how i like
it yes with milk
just one ingredient and you remembered
it
anyway no sign of wilcox maybe we should
talk about deets of the case plan our
next move grab a little chow
no neither i brought these
nutrition bricks i have um
original no flavor and whole wheat no
flavor
nutrition bricks sound great or
we could grab a little street meat kind
of a classic stakeout food but
whatever huh meat
from the street sounds like a fun treat
i'm a poet and didn't even know i was
rhyming those words
but it happened anyway it's a great idea
partner
let's grab some free meat okay
now the first step in learning how to
cook is learning how to taste
so close your eyes and open your mouth
this isn't burning man boil
tell me what i'm eating fine it's a
shark vermont cabot
now describe what you taste cheese
and cheese
okay that's good but try being more
descriptive
i know you love peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches
why their components have a long shelf
life they're cost-effective and they're
so simple a child could make them
okay i was looking for more of an
emotional connection
for example my favorite meal is a simple
roast chicken and potatoes
it was the only dish my mother knew how
to cook and when i eat it
i feel as though i am once again inside
her womb
what's your story behind a pb j i want a
sandwich i make a sandwich
i eat the sandwich
joining us for lunch sir oh no i've
already consumed the required calories
for this day period yummy
i'm one caller away i can't believe we
figured it out and i can't believe it
took you this
long yogurt is literally your one thing
okay
okay well i'm just saying if the sound
were eating damp rice i would have
gotten it
immediately you know many people think
that
scrambled eggs are the easiest food to
make
that is incredibly foolish they
are a highly nuanced and complicated
dish
okay now go ahead and pour your eggs
right into the pan
nice and slow
oh okay now what do i do oh boy hey we
hear that sizzle that means the heat is
a little too high on those eggs
well the the higher the heat the faster
the eggs cook the sooner kevin eats am i
incorrect no you make an excellent point
but we don't want to feed kevin burned
garbage
cooking is about patience
are you completely insane you never
salt can the pan the hand the hand is
the middle man
okay what you did is the culinary
equivalent of
unprotected sex
you know what you sir are not ready to
scramble eggs
hand over your spatula fine
i only wish in return i could get back
all the time i just wasted on this
futile project
i'm just gonna make kevin plain toast
for breakfast oh
that is low what did the officiants say
when you got married not much
when gay marriage was legalized we
weren't sure if or when it was going to
be struck down so
speed was of the essence do you
kevin yes and do you yes yes we do
we're married i remarked afterwards that
i wish the officiant had been more
efficient it was very funny kevin still
talks about it
maybe i should open with that zinger it
is amazingly funny
i'm just not sure this is the right
crowd for it no zinger
no haiku then i have nothing maybe i
should wing it
love it sustains you
it's like oatmeal okay
okay not bad for winging it i lied
it took me two hours to right there
interesting
very very interesting guys
captain holt has no pants on um
what he has no pants on is what here are
the facts
at 11 55 a.m captain holt walked past us
holding a hot bowl of soup
at 12 03 p.m i heard him yell ouch
then at 1207 he called gina into his
office
she entered holding nothing one minute
later she left holding an opaque bag
captain holt's pants were in that bag
his knees are in the breeze
he's in his undies that evidence is
circumstantial oh
so you guys want visual confirmation not
really done
hey captain i just need you to sign
something at my desk real quick
just leave it on the couch dismissed
okay
sir you're gonna freak yo-yo maze in the
precinct and he's giving out autographs
yo-yo ma is on tour in australia right
now
how would you know that i'm choking on a
lozenge
i'm gonna die i got to take no
no no i swallowed it i blowed it it's
right
hey hey i made you another bowl of soup
since you spilled yours earlier
but you're gonna have to come over here
to get it all right peralta i'm sick are
you wasting time so yes
i spilled some minestrone in my pants
and i'm sitting in my underwear happy
yes
sir i need you to sign off on look at us
just three people with pants on having a
normal conversation
yep no story here i'm worried our night
shift morale problem has gotten worse
yeah you think i'm sorry i'm exhausted
my wife says when i get tired i get
night sassy night sassy hearing problems
much
sorry should i just go tell everyone to
buck up and do their jobs
no the squad's only on night shift
because they came down to florida to
save jake and me
it's my responsibility to fix this i'm
going to brighten the mood by
telling a few jokes try this one on for
size
i don't care for cheese i'm a
curd mugen
well you're too tired for humor
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to answer an age-old question
right what's amy's deal is she single no
we're dating
come on the question is who here does
the best impression of captain raymond
holt
you'll be judged on voice body language
and overall lack of flair
everyone will perform the same scenario
captain holt eating a marshmallow for
the very first time
let the halt off begin what is this
glutinous monstrosity before me the
sugar in this is quite sweet
that's your whole impression i can hear
him doing that looks like a
sticky pillow i don't care for it
classical music
what's going on here what are you doing
captain hey nothing just
eating some marshmallows care for one
marshmallow
i knew it good morning boyle
oh good morning captain holt after our
disagreement yesterday i went online to
read your culinary vlogs and scoff
to my dismay i actually learned
something about how food
tells a story so i made kevin this
it's warm it's a croak monsieur kevin
and i shared one on a rainy afternoon in
paris
on our first anniversary it's one of our
most treasured memories
i'm sure it's not up to your standards
but kevin seemed to enjoy it
so thank you for your guidance
it's gross huh no
it's perfect he's a natural chef
now i know how salieri felt
you